hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmccontrol
cm.l2-3.4.2 establish and enforce
security configuration settings for
information technology products employed
in organizational systems oh boy I know
I'm excited too
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 1071 compliance stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news for you you
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it so here we are cmmc control
cm.l2-3.4.2 establish and enforce
security configuration settings for
information technology products employed
in organizational systems yeah so how do
we do that right well let's break it
down in a few words first we have to
establish which can be done via
documentation of configuration settings
then we have to show that what that they
are enforced which can be done in
various ways but likely the easiest way
is to give the demonstrations of policy
enforcement in other words have the
assessor look over your shoulder and
then show them the policy baby so think
group policies showing that they're
LinkedIn enforced as one as one small
sample guys I'm have you ever been
through this right but if you're an I.T
guy right if you're a CEO stay tuned I'm
gonna give you some good stuff but hang
on because I'm gonna tell a story for
the I.T people all right have you ever
sat there and you're like looking over
somebody's shoulder and you're looking
at group policy and you're like hey man
cool policy but um it doesn't do
anything and the IT guy is like what do
you mean I'm like well you didn't right
click and actually enforce the thing or
you didn't link it those things actually
are necessary and believe it or not your
assessors are going to look for that
stuff so Mike's public service
announcement for this week is go look at
your group policy and go find out what's
enforced and what's linked and make sure
your group policies that you worked
really hard to write are actually
enforced all right now
Public Service Announcement over just
having a little bit of fun today let's
check out what the assessors are looking
for and how to make them happy first
thing an assessor is looking for
determine if security configuration
settings for information technology
products employed in the system are
established and include the Baseline
configuration so number one uh you could
I mean so the written answer is easy on
this all right see organizations Network
documentation on file right so that's
the easy answer to that one but again
what are they looking for all right they
want to know the security configuration
settings uh are actually like
established like they're in a policy or
they're in documentation and that
they're included in the Baseline
configuration so again you got to make
sure that stuff's in the actual
documentation you're ready to show it to
them be like hey this is our policy this
is what we do uh these are the rules of
our Network
assessment Point number two determine if
security configuration settings for
information technology products employed
in the system are enforced there it is I
told you it was coming if you watched
earlier this is why I implemented see
organizations Network documentation on
uh on file and shoulder surfing may be
required to view evidence of current
security configuration okay like at the
end of the day a lot of these controls
are not just gonna be like your cool off
a cool awesome written answer it's also
going to be that someone's going to come
look over your shoulder during the
actual certification assessment so uh
there's a heads up on that now if you
are a defense contractor I got a feeling
you are and you are struggling to figure
all this stuff out and you're watching
like 20 of my videos I promise watching
The Marvelous Mrs maisel and binging on
that is way better than binging on this
face I like it but not that much so if
you're binging on my face it's a great
time to remember that an on-call we work
with defense contractors just like you
who've had this D fars nist itar and
cmmc compliant stuff drop their laughs
like a seagull on a sunny day baby we
teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps gray areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance is your
secret weapon to land more Defense work
with higher profit margins now that is
what becoming an on-call compliance hero
can do for you if you're looking for
more help getting compliant our
compliance experts are always on call
for you visit cmmc complianceecrets.com
or check out the Bible below for links
to get help right now if you love the
content we're putting up out here for
you help help us out with a big thumbs
up on that like button or even better
smash the Subscribe button to get the
latest compliance content as soon as our
compliances rolled out until next
compliance tip my friends stay safe and
secure out there hit us in the comments
below and let us know what you'd like to
know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance I
love it when you binge on my face but I
like it even better when you call us and
we can actually just get Hands-On and
give you the help you really need and
I'll see you on the next one
foreign
[Music]